joining us now Secretary of State Mike
Pompeo mr. secretary I know we have you
on for a lot of reasons China top among
them I we've been friends a long time
I've known you for a long time you have
now you as Secretary of State are in the
position of negotiating some very
significant real challenging issues as
involved safety and security for the
world you're watching all this unfold in
this country and you see people that are
unwilling to even protect the innocent
citizens in their cities and states and
I know I know you as a person well
enough to know that that's our first
that's the first job of government isn't
it Sean thanks for having me on tonight
when I watch this it reminds me of what
our founders understood most clearly
that the primary purpose a primary
purpose of our governor secure freedom
and liberty basic protections for its
citizens and so when you watch these
things happening we're mayors and
governors refused to take the actions to
protect the innocent to protect people
who were trying to live their lives you
were talking about businesspeople just a
bit ago to protect their property rights
this is the most fundamental duty of
government and to see that not happening
in cities and states across America is
disheartening and these government's
need to step up you know before there's
a lot going on with China today we're
going to keep these pictures up and go
back to our reporters in just a second
I'm not going to spend a lot of time on
it I can't I I read that you said that
john bolton was a liar i know in
conversations with me he didn't tell me
the truth at the direct specific
conversations I can recall I have all
these quotes of john bolton and then i
mentioned him on the radio today and i
can recap them but praising the
president nobody's been tougher on china
president's been strong with russia
President on Iran the President on North
Korea for example
I don't know who he's arguing with but
it seems to be this john bolton then
that john bolton and it's a little
disappointing but i guess we've seen the
president get stabbed in the back by a
lot of people at this point not even
relevant to me you know Sean it's both
sad and dangerous I've read the book in
its entirety but the excerpts I've seen
there's lots of falsehoods there's lots
of lies contained there indeed the cover
itself the study in the room and he was
in the
room isn't even completely true the
President and others myself included had
to cut him out of meetings because he
was leaking or he'd twist things or he'd
lie it was it was a really difficult
situation where John Bolton thought he
was more important than the President of
the United States and the American
people and the core story Sean that
somehow the president took action so you
could get reelected that his foreign
policy was driven by that he didn't kill
Qasem Soleimani to get reelected he
isn't pushing a back against Chinese
Communist Party to get reelected he
didn't get out of Paris climate Accord
to get reelected he did this to secure
the basic rights and security for every
American this president's foreign policy
is something that John Bolton should
have been proud of and instead he
stepped away in a way that fundamentally
misrepresents what we've done and
frankly the information he has released
puts criminal liability squarely on him
we all saw what's happened when people
leaks classified information like Edward
Snowden what john bolton did here is not
dissimilar from that and while we'll
leave open for the Justice Department to
take its action this kind of information
getting out it presents real risk and
real harm to the United States of
America well his half a vote for the
ever forgetful Joe Biden he can ask
himself these questions Baghdad he's
dead Soleimani he's dead the leader of
al-qaeda in Yemen is dead I don't see
any possibility of President Trump he
gave nothing to Kim jong-un nothing at
all we got a lot in return just a little
bit of his time and I don't see this
president giving 150 billion in cash and
other currencies to the Iranian mullahs
so his half a vote to Biden will go in
that direction on to more important
things
we have Peter Navarro and and you are
taking lead on China apparently that we
have now issues involving the trade deal
and other new developments this is
significant tonight so I spent a day
with my counterparts boss in Hawaii last
week trying to understand why on earth
the Chinese Communist Party is engaged
in the activities that they are and I
think we understand it its ideological
for them whether that's what's taking
place between China and India today
today the State Department announced
that for propaganda outlets here in the
United States the State Department is
going to put restrictions on these are
arms of the Chinese government that
President Obama and Vice President Biden
allowed to operate
really inside the United States spewing
communist propaganda all throughout the
United States of America this State
Department president from State
Department is taking action against that
this is a president who understands that
the Chinese Communist Party and
globalists here in the United States
have worked together to put real harm
and real risk here to the United States
President Trump's not going to permit
that to continue to happen one person
that I would say is more right than
anybody in the world about China we
learned this with the coronavirus mister
secretaries Donald Trump and I didn't I
don't think that any of his sons got a
sweetheart 1.5 billion dollar deal with
the Bank of China in a field of endeavor
that they didn't know much about one
last thing I do know on a private basis
but people people have told me you went
to bat to get American citizens home
during the corona virus from one country
after another
it's an untold story thank you for doing
all that I heard about a group of
missionaries that you got back to the
country safely approved you know what
great job sir thank you